what was it like for you filming that
scene where you get to take off
everything that makes starlight's
costume because
i don't know it just like it was almost
cathartic for me watching just like
peel away all of the things that you
know some
might not realize is what it takes to
bring
a certain type of human like a look for
a human being
to scream that way yeah no you're
exactly right i was so gung-ho about
doing that
specifically and they didn't request
this of me but i requested it
i wear that outfit and um i
really wanted to have that moment where
i take off the outfit and the wig and
all that stuff but also you see me take
out
the um the butt and like
breast implants that they give me for
the outfit
and i said like well i have these little
silicone inserts to kind of enhance my
body and make it look more like a barbie
that's not my own body and so i was like
we need to show
that this is not real because if
we don't we're contributing even though
we're not
um we're making ultimately kind of a
negative commentary on her outfit
because she is covert she is playing the
game this season
she's wearing it for a reason she's not
supporting it she's just like i said
playing the game
but i want people to see that this is
not my body i want people to see this is
not real
that sure there are women out there with
that bodies but i just kind of wanted to
be able to
acknowledge the fact that more often
than not you know
that ideal isn't something to strive for
because it doesn't exist and
perfectionism especially in
bodies is a feudal pursuit and we see it
too much and shows and we're not aware
of
how much makeup people wear or what's
helping them
achieve that ideal and so i thought what
a cool opportunity to take out these
silicon inserts
and this butt pad and show that this
barbie-esque
physique is totally artificial
um so and then the the the whole point
of the
scene being that she's revealing you
know that she is
wearing a facade and you peek behind it
for the first time
it's a short scene but i think it's
really really
important to show it and i'm really glad
we show it in the first episode straight
off the bat
i think it's really informative of where
she's
at and it sets her up for the rest of
her trajectory that season
absolutely jumping to i believe it's
episode three now
there's one moment there where
homelander
demands that starlight kill huey
her eyes light up and from our
perspective the thing that stops her
is the distraction from butcher had
butcher and them not
been there lurking around the corner
what do you think she would have done
it's interesting because um people have
brought that up
and i have always thought without a
doubt including when we were filming it
that she would not have killed huey i
feel like i know that character in my
bones
deeply too and i think
this season sort of one of the big
themes for her
this season is that she's wearing a mask
and she's trying to
maintain that rock solid facade as much
as she can so
i in my mind in that moment as her eyes
light up
she's she's you know reaching into the
depths of her
brain to figure out what what the hell
she's going to do while pacifying
homelander to
signify to him that she's carbonating
with her powers
um but i do not think that she would
have
killed huey at all
i can't imagine it anymore no i chose
like my choice was yeah
exactly that that she's showing her eyes
light up she's just kind of
trying to figure it out quickly but she
you know there
it's like when she blasts him and she
falls back because she has to i mean
if you want to talk about a hypothetical
world her powers are really
powerful so it could be something like
blasting a wall next to huey and having
good aim and
creating a distraction and making it
seem like there's been destruction and
then figuring it out but
no no she would not have killed huey